maybe Obama's gay and maybe he was
smoking crack with the gay dude and
whatever so okay it's Friday let's do it
this man named Larry Saint Claire who
Larry Sinclair uh went on Tucker
Carlson's show and he claims that about
30 years ago he was having sex and
snorting coke and smoking crack with
Barack Obama I just want to say one
thing before we throw to this I remember
this is going to sound nuts but I
remember back in 2008 or so seeing this
guy Larry Sinclair there was a video of
him on MySpace that was going viral
saying this exact same thing so it isn't
as if I swear to you I remember seeing
that so it isn't as if this guy just
magically appeared out of nowhere I
don't know if he's completely insane I
mean something doesn't seem quite right
I've given you enough of an intro video
you're just a guy who's in town for the
night and it sounds like you're looking
to parties yeah pulled up in a bar
outside and there's this guy that's
introduced to me as Barack Obama I had
given Barack 250 to pay for Coke I start
putting a line on a CD tray to snort and
next thing I know he's got a little pipe
and he's smoking so I just started
rubbing my hand along this thigh to see
where it was going and it went the
direction I had intended it to go even
though you had sex with him twice you
did cocaine with him watch him smoke
crack twice you had no idea who he was I
had no idea who he was asked the obvious
question what was Obama like on crack
um is it your sense that that sewer bomb
is just transactional or these bisexual
or like what is this it definitely
wasn't barack's first time and I would
almost be willing to bet you it wasn't
as long
the guy's running for president and
credible information comes out for these
smoking crack and having sex with dudes
that seems like a story well it would be
a story of the media really cared about
telling people the truth all right I
want to say I I don't know if it's true
in a certain way I don't care if it's
true I don't care if Obama is gay my
husband's gay not that there's anything
wrong with that
um but there's something here because if
this man had said he was having sex with
say Donald Trump or Mitch McConnell or
insert any Republican this would be the
front page of the New York Times every
day endlessly Isabel Obama smoking crack
go
every time I watch that video Dave I
probably have watched that promo 45
times at this point I just get a kick
out of Tucker trying not to laugh it's
the first time I've ever seen a little
smile at the corner of his mouth when
he's really seriously listening to
someone because you're right the open
joke is this would be the highlight
number one trending thing on every
social media platform this would be 24 7
on every News network and on the front
page of every newspaper if we were
talking about a republican candidate for
president or even a former president at
that I do find the timing awfully
coincidental while the Obamas are doing
this glorifying press tour of their
family so perhaps there is some weight
there uh we'll just have to see if the
truth does eventually come out but it's
it's awfully interesting to me how the
media is refusing to acknowledge this
conversation and how we have to bring it
to Independent Media sources and that's
true of so many important stories going
into 2024 stop listening to the
mainstream cable television if you want
the full truth Alex I know you're a drug
slash racism expert there's sort of like
a funny race piece of this which is that
Sinclair is saying he snorted the coke
while Obama smoked the crack I don't
know something seems interesting to me
about that
well put on your tinfoil hat please
because this is why my biological
stepfather had Larry on the show now
alone everybody saw in 2008 you know
this press conference when before before
Obama was President he said that he did
these things right everybody kind of
swept it under the rug because there was
not a lot of you know corroboration to
the story it was just one guy's word
against Barack Obama and obviously
you're going to believe a senator not a
crackhead but recently letters have come
out from Barack Obama's ex-girlfriend
talking about how he fantasized about
having gay sex now I don't care if
Barack Obama's gay actually I think that
makes him more likable that makes him
more authentic we said oh I'm a gay man
and I'm married to you know Mike but I'm
not I'm not saying that's true or false
what I am saying is true real quick I
just want to end it on this it is on
autobiography he said that he
experimented with cocaine and marijuana
so he's tried drugs oftentimes we talk
about uh you know race problem in this
world I think it's that we have a lot of
fatherless non-traditional homes and
Brock comes from that upbringing he
wasn't raised by his dad he was raised
by his mom mainly and so oftentimes
those people use drugs so the idea that
Barack Obama uses drugs he smoke
cigarettes I think he did I think that's
true what did he do with Larry Sinclair
I don't know is he gay probably and
that'd be cool if he would just admit it
so I mean that's just how I feel about
Barack Obama and those are the cold hard
facts that I think but also I'm a
conspiracy theorist so you know take
that for what you will well you read the
foil hat on though Alex because Beyond
just the letters he actually tweeted out
that he was upset seeing all the books
that were being removed from elementary
schools here in Florida Dave uh that
you're very familiar with the content of
because those were the Books That Shaped
his childhood if you know anything about
those books they are graphic gay porn
graphic novels so is that really the
book that you want to say shaped your
childhood former Mr President I don't
know